There are over two billion school-aged individuals
living in the world today.
That's more young people
than any other time in human history.
That's billions of minds
teaming with uninhibited creativity.
That's billions of curious souls.
The world's youth is the embodiment
of the world's future,
and that future has no limits
because each and every young person
brings a completely new
and a completely unique perspective
to the world around them.
Ayana is passionately pursuing
the meaning of life, among other things.
What will life come to mean to her
and to her closest friends?
Will future smartphone owners download
a student-built mood app,
and will they prefer iteration number one
or number two?
Will Sophia become an Olympian,
a teacher,
an advocate for world peace,
or will she become all three?
And will Tyler's obsession with space
and his pursuit of infinity
lead him to travel beyond the world his ideas
and the ideas of his peers
will most certainly define?
Picture the collective potential and the ideas
of over two billion passionate young people.
TED-Ed is thrilled to announce
a new program that aims to give them
the space and time
to pursue those passions
and to support them
in presenting those ideas
in the form of short, TED-like talks.
The program is called TED-Ed Clubs.
The mission:
to celebrate the best ideas
of young people around the world.
Here's how it works.
Visit ed.ted.com
and fill out the club facilitator application.
Once approved, you'll receive access
to a set of free tools
designed to help you start a TED-Ed Club
at your school.
There are 13 suggested meetings.
Each meeting helps club members
gain a discrete presentation skill.
In the final meetings,
club members present their ideas
in the form of short, TED-like talks.
Teachers, you can nominate presentations
to be featured on TED-Ed
or at the annual TED Youth conference.
And students, the world is waiting
to be redefined
by your biggest,
smallest,
boldest,
quirkiest,
bravest,
most inspiring,
and most brilliant ideas!